you tweeted once again quote when I
talked to Chad gbt I'm talking to an NPC
was going to be interesting and perhaps
scary is when AI becomes a first person
player uh so what does that step look
like I really like that tweet
that step between NPC to first person
player
what's required for that
is that kind of what we've been talking
about
this kind of in external source of
coherence and inspiration of how to take
the leap into the unknown that we humans
do the search man search for meaning
llm's search for meaning
and I don't know of the language model
is the right Paradigm because it is
doing too much it's giving you too much
and it's hard once you have too much to
take away from it again
the way in which our own mind works is
not that we train a language model in
our own mind and after the language
model is there we build a personal self
on top of it that then relates to the
world
there is something that is being built
right there is a game engine that is
being built there is a language of
thought that is being developed that
allows different parts of the mind to
talk to each other and this is a bit of
a speculative hypothesis that is
language of Sword is there but I suspect
that it's important for the way in which
our own minds work and
building these principles into a system
um
might be more straightforward way to a
first person AI so to something that
first creates an intentional self and
then creates a personal self so the way
in which this seems to be working I
think is that when the game engine is
built in your mind it's not just
following Radiance where you are
stimulated by the environment and then
end up with having a solution to how the
world works I suspect that building this
game engine in your own mind
does require intelligence it's a
constructive task
where at times you need to reason
and
this is a task that we are fulfilling in
the first years of our life
so during the first year of its life an
infant is building a lot of structure
about the world that does inquire
experiments and some first principles
reasoning and so on and in this time
there is usually no personal self there
is a first person perspective but it's
not a person this notion that you are a
human being that is interacting in a
social context and is confronted with an
immutable World in which objects are
fixed and can no longer be changed in
which the dream can no longer be
influenced as something that emerges a
little bit later in our life and I
personally suspect that this is
something that our ancestors had known
and we have forgotten
because I suspect that it's damn plain
sight in Genesis 1 in this first book of
the Bible where it's being described
that this creative spirit is hovering
over the substrate and then is creating
a boundary between the word model and
sphere of ideas Earth and Heaven as
they're being described there and then
it's uh creating
contrast and then dimensions and then
space and then it creates organic shapes
and solids and liquids and builds about
from them and creates plants and animals
gives them all their names and once
that's done it creates another spirit in
its own image but it creates it as man
and woman as something that thinks of
itself as a human being and puts it into
this world
and the Christians mistranslate this I
suspect when they say this is the
description of the creation of the
physical Universe by a supernatural
being I think this is literally a
description of how in every mind a
universe is being created as some kind
of game engine
by a creative Spirit our first
Consciousness that emerges in our mind
even before we are born
and that creates the the interaction
between organism and wealth and once
that is built and trained the personal
self is being created and we only
remember being the personal self we no
longer remember how we created the game
engine so God in this View
is the first creative mind in there it's
the first Consciousness in the early
days in the early months yes of
development and let's go there do you
still have this outer mind that creates
your sense of your of whether you're
being loved by the world or not
and what your place in the world is
right it's something that is not
yourself that is producing this it's
your mind that does it so there is an
outer mind that basically is an agent
that determines who you are with respect
to the world and while you are stuck
being that personal self in this world
until you get to Stage six and you
destroy the boundary
right and we all do this I think earlier
and it's a small glimpses and maybe
sometimes we can remember what it was
like when we were a small child and get
some glimpses into how it's been but for
most people that rarely happens